like pajamas might seem like an
important gift but for a child going
through a time of crisis
pajamas can be a comforting reminder of
better times and it's a really important
gift for them
and that is the drive behind a charity
called djs for pjs
and that group's founder darcy nabors
joins us live now via zoom on this
friday good morning darcy we're so happy
to talk to you
good morning how are you great i hope
you're doing great too
this group your group darcy has
collected more than a hundred
thousand new pairs of pajamas since 2003
which is incredible
but you have a new announcement to make
this morning
we do after having you know
events every april in a parking lot at
kohl's and collecting
hundreds you know over a hundred
thousand pairs of pajamas um
we needed to kind of pivot and
especially due to covet the last couple
of years so
we have a huge announcement that we're
making at 10 30 uh
this morning here in the parking lot
coveted
you know friendly at the city national
bank building
that announcement is that we are now
going to be giving
three different charities every year
what we're calling pjs in perpetuity
which means that three charities uh
child haven
uh safe nest and saint jude's rants for
children
will all receive 150 pairs pajamas a
year that's 1500
forever that means every single year
these charities will receive that
donation and we are still collecting
to grow our endowment funds so that we
can continue to do this
and to put into perpetuity so we're
super excited about this announcement
today
oh well congratulations and that is so
exciting uh for someone who maybe hasn't
heard of this organization you've been
doing this now for almost 20 years
how did djs for pjs get its start darcy
well it all happened during a class
project that i had to do with
leadership las vegas in 2003 i had to
visit child haven
and i was put in a room of three to four
year olds and this little boy crawled up
in my heart
and at the end of that i went to the
parking lot
and i i started crying and i called my
mother and
i said mom i've got to do something for
these kids and
she said darcy with all your media
connections why don't you do something
like djs for pj so
i took that back to the class they voted
voted on it as a class project
and it took off from there and we've
held this you know every year since
um and it has absolutely been one of the
most significant things that i've been a
part of
um in my entire career and to see little
children come to the table and dump
their piggy banks out and
you know mothers and companies just come
and donate
you know hundreds of pairs of pajamas
for these kids that have been abused and
neglected
is just so heartwarming when when you
look at vegas we are a very
very giving community and it's been
something that it's been
um i it gets me emotional thinking about
um all the years that we've put this
together and then now
exciting about this new chapter of the
event yeah and all the children that
feel so special because of you um darcy
really quickly we're almost out of time
but how can someone donate if they would
like to get involved
yeah visit our website at djsforpjs.org
and that's djs for pjs.org and there's a
quick donate button on there it's
it's simple it's easy um and we look
forward to receiving donations so that
we can continue to provide
new pajamas and look at how cute they
are oh
yeah i mean who can't go and you know
want to give little kids pajamas so
it's it's a lot of fun little pajamas
well darcy thanks for what you've done
for the community and gosh
especially after this year of cova this
is even more important than it already
was so thank you so much and
congratulations with everything all
right take care you too